nur deine stimme bekannt ist live
verstörend sein aber wir reden über das
packen und über ziemlich kräftige wenn
ich etwas gedauert und es bekommen beim
neuen video
ich hab heute wieder den christian dabei
mal kurz vor
ich bin christian ich erwische mich
durch die haben uns hier versammelt um
neues video zu drehen genau wie haben
uns versammelt um ein neues video zu
drehen was sollte man auch sonst machen
auf jeden fall ganz gedacht was machen
wir eigentlich von video
denn wenn es christian auf die idee doch
bestimmt auch mal auf die idee gleich
noch mal deine freunde auf snapshot weil
sie gerade runter gefallen sind
das habe ich dann natürlich auch gemacht
und wir sind jetzt so weit gekommen dass
wir jetzt auf der stufe sind also
gefragt und dann kam die idee dass wir
machen auf jeden fall gibt es heute ein
video dazu also ihr habt uns jetzt
irgendwelche typisch mädchen in sachen
oder angewohnheiten von mädchen halt
geschickt per snap chat das gucken wir
es jetzt gleich an und wir machen dann
eine aufklärung unserer meinung nach
warum er das macht oder was er damit
bezwecken wollte verstehst du ja ich
verstehe dass man fast genau so machen
wir das also typisch mädchen machen zum
beispiel das ganz doof gesagt zu zweit
auf die toilette das ist ja mega
ausgelöst aber das fällt so ein
einfaches beispiel damit ihr wisst worum
es heute geht und dann suchen wir aus
was die da machen
über eine treppe geredet was auch zum
video es doch logisch warum man das
macht damit sich wackelt oder nicht ich
kann das nicht nachvollziehen ich kann
mir noch nichts denken also auch so
machen das wirklich habe ich noch nie
aufgefallen also in der schule macht das
keiner
also kann ich vorher nicht okay marko
marin so zu sagen hat ich würde das
jetzt nicht sagen dass das nur mädchen
machen das machen ja auch jungs na ja
wenn ich jetzt eine heiße braut entdeckt
habe machte ehrlich immer man guckt sich
ja immer so ein bisschen ja ein bisschen
guckt man halt immer um ist doch logisch
stück du machst das damit du ermitteln
kannst oder ein besseres gefühl hast ein
besseres selbstgefühl ob du da jetzt
eine chance ist dann egal jungs machen
das auch fertig oder auch nicht nächste
sache ganz einfach ging schott von was
man auch nicht alle jungs und mädchen
eben doch vernunft mal klarstellen
genannt darauf sein dass das geld wieder
zügig haben wird na ja bei uns nicht nur
das doch gar nicht schlimm wenn ich mich
mit menschen zum ski bewerber treffen
stand ja auch in ihrem bett so gut war
das jetzt im opa alter was laberst du
was ist denn ein slowakischer kleiner
junge immer damals für jetzt netflix und
schild man sieht mich gar nicht mehr
keine ahnung auf die frage man schlaf
einfach mit denen ein bett und fertig
ist wenn die beste freundin daheim ist
wird man echt richtig zuletzt also das
herz ich jetzt komm ich ein alter aber
das kann ich voll verstehen ohne witze
ich krieg manchmal so snaps viele davon
sind auch erst zwölf oder 13 auf 14
manche sind natürlich auch schon älter
es ist ja so nie mein ziel ist also von
12 bis 30 30
und ich denke mir so was macht ihr da
gerade ohne scheiß was macht ihr da das
sind das sind keine normalen mädchen die
küche manchmal snap schicken sondern das
ist einfach ich meine dass ich auch
nicht böse ich glaube nicht dass hier
immer so sein aber manchmal denke ich
bei einigen was was bezweckt dass jetzt
gerade zum beispiel wochen bei wenn
einer aus dem bett steht die andere
liegt da und die springt drauf und beide
freuen sich
weißt du hast gar nicht zugehört doch
ich muss mir also wenn man jünger ist
versteht man findet man hat sachen
witzig die allerdings nicht verstehen
junge ich will kein stellt mir machen
okay willst du mal den nächsten du
fängst jetzt direkt mit dem nächsten
wir haben endlich kann ich mal sagen
eher finster sogleich das posten und
wenn ihr dann schreibt man nicht dann
mache ich das trotzdem mit anderen
filter drauf und schickte noch mal wo
mit dem filter ist dass danach gut und
dann geht das auch gut aus weil als meta
meta man so viel rausholen ohne scheiße
sie hat ja ich weiß ist er sieht aus wie
kartoffel macht später drauf erst
topmodel wenn sie durch die kartoffeln
butter drauf topmodel deine stimme
gleich verstörend sein aber wir packen
und über ziemlich crafting gericht oder
wir legen im weg und so oft in sachsen
oder so und dann fangen wir etwas und zu
richtig hart anzusehen aber so richtig
schießt wenn man sehen kann ich noch
will
du machst du machen wir das machen die
trompeter hören eine trompete machen
ja es gut läuft so ein programm damit
kann man seine konten auf jeden fall bei
namics mehr verpassen wollt abonniert
mich und nicht ihn an sein instagram ist
hier eingeblendet könnte ja mal
vorbeischauen da willst was ich mehr
er hat irgendwie 100 follower verloren
weil er nicht mehr bei mir im video war
das video macht stimmt doch gar nicht
hier oben links jetzt auch ein video
könnt ihr auch gerne vorbei stand auch
in der video beschreibung von links
selbst insidern bei auch als engel wir
sehen uns am nächsten sonntag wiederholt
drei leute